philippe quelle faille en juriste et
chercheur associé en droit international
public à l'université paris 2 et ancien
secrétaire général de la fidh et h la
fédération internationale des droits de
l'homme
bonsoir filet kalfayan merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france pour
parler de ce conflit finalement assez
méconnu quelle peut être l'issue des
pourparlers aujourd'hui à moscou
très faible pour la raison suivante
c'est que les principes qui aurait été
négocié jusqu'à présent donc sous
l'égide du groupe de minsk et des pays
médiateurs
or il était aujourd'hui de ne sont plus
du tout applicable
c'est à dire que pour que ces principes
soient impeccables il aurait fallu que
premièrement l'azerbaïdjan soit un pays
démocratiques respectant l'état de droit
et deuxièmement qu'il y ait une
confiance mutuelle
un bon or ce conflit en réalité c'est un
conflit qui est vieux de 100 ans
c'est à dire que ce territoire est
disputée entre arméniens et
azerbaïdjanais depuis 100 ans
il ya eu également des guerres donc
entre 1918 et 1921 il ya eu un donc un
statut politique qui n'a jamais été
définies pour pour ce territoire
pour preuve un laser bête gens qui
incluait cette région autonome du
nagorny karabach depuis donc le 5
juillet 1921 en fait n'inclut même pas
ce territoire dans sa déclaration
d'indépendance de 1991 puisque la
déclaration d'indépendance de 1991 se
réfère à la déclaration d'indépendance
de 1918 1920 et à l'époque le territoire
du nagorno karabagh qui n'était pas
attaché donc à l'azerbaïdjan
qui fait qu'il ya un statut bancal qui
existe depuis 100 ans mais la raison
pour laquelle rien ne pourra plus
aboutir sur la base de ces principes
c'est qu'il ya une telle haine qui s'est
développé mon qui existait déjà
historiquement mais que cette guerre va
renforcer pour je ne sais combien de
générations
on ne peut pas imaginer un processus
d'autodétermination tel qu'il est conçu
par le droit international c'est à dire
[Musique]
un processus qui se fait à l'intérieur
des frontières reconnues de
l'azerbaïdjan donc aujourd'hui la seule
solution possible c'est de reconnaître
la sécession c'est la reconnaître
l'indépendance de ce territoire
les arméniens d'ailleurs ce soir il ya
un troisième élément c'est la turquie
qui vient s'inviter dans dans ce conflit
ça risque de compliquer les choses
ben je pense d'abord que la turquie et
est à l'origine cette de cette attaque
c'est accueilli ce sont eux qui a incité
donc à l' attaque d'une certaine manière
puisque il avait apporté un soutien
diplomatique et militaire sans réserve
est bon la turquie on le saura peut-être
plus tard un jour a bien entendu ses
ambitions vers l'asie centrale mais elle
est peut-être aussi le jouet de
de puissance pour l'instant qui ne se
sont pas trop montré il ya un élément
qui lie la russie à l'arménie est un
contrat de défense mutuelle comment
réagir si ce conflit se durcit la russie
sera obligée de s'impliquer
militairement
non la russie ne pourrait s'impliquer et
que si la turquie effectivement attaqué
les frontières de l'arménie mais
j'imagine mal la russie utilisé son sa
base militaire d'arménie pour intervenir
dans le conflit du karabagh la russie
qui intervient on le voit beaucoup plus
activement ce qui l'inquiète c'est
cesser les rumeurs de d'envoi en tout
cas de jihadistes en provenance de syrie
encouragé par la turquie et c'est un
vrai un vrai danger c'est un vrai danger
et d'ailleurs c'est assez intéressant de
voir cette inquiétude parce que il y a
le 5 juillet 1921 quand staline décide
arbitrairement sans aucune décision
d'ailleurs d'aucun organe constitué
d'attribuer ce territoire à les arbitres
jean il le fait précisément pour les
mêmes raisons c'est à dire que à
l'époque il y avait donc des conflits
entre arméniens et azerbaïdjanais en
réalité la russie de l'époque la russie
bolchévique craignait que cela tourne à
un conflit entre chrétiens et musulmans
donc déjà à l'époque la russie
bolchévique avait se soucie des
musulmans
aujourd'hui 100 ans après il se trouve
que précisément la menace musulmane joue
encore un rôle
maintenant on va savoir si la russie est
vraiment soucieuse de stopper ces
djihadistes ou pas alors bien entendu
les djihadistes ne représente pas
l'ensemble des musulmans mais c'est
quand même un vrai sujet là et la france
dans tout ça si je puis dire est-ce
qu'elle a des leviers pour faire
pression sur l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie
pour revenir à la raison
écoutez elle a probablement un plus de
levier sur l'armée nique sur
l'azerbaïdjan
même si la france est un fournisseur
d'armes l'azerbaïdjan en tout cas elle
était elle n'est pas actuellement au
cours du conflit mais elle a été donc
c'est clair que l'azerbaïdjan est un
plus gros client que l'arménie en tout
cas alors on vous dit que ce conflit
dure maintenant depuis deux puissantes
en omois en tout cas depuis 28 ans le
processus du groupe de minsk n'arrive
pas à faire grand chose
ils ont toujours misé sur le statu quo
finalement on le voit aujourd'hui
l'arménie a du mal militairement
est ce que ça change la donne et ce
statu quo n'est plus tenable
écoutez je ne sais pas si l'arménie a du
mal militairement jeu on a du mal à
comprendre à travers les informations
aux médias numériques quelle est la
situation réelle sur le front mais bon
toujours est il que
c'est sûr que halo terre enfin moyen
terme si le conflit devait durer la
situation deviendrait difficile pour
alarmer ni parce que nous n'avons pas un
pays comme la turquie qui est l'homme
qui serait là pour nous approvisionner
en armes
merci beaucoup philippe kalfayan d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce soir sur arte
france